lady kills it what's this outfit that
ladies wear you
know what's she
holding a [__] twisty tus a Mastadon
[Music]
tus yeah yeah oh so
Pennsylvanian this whole thing this is
if you found the middle of Pennsylvania
like if you found if you mathematically
found the middle of Pennsylvania this is
it right here this lady standing there
with a Mastadon Tusk and this
outfit that all [__] counselors in
high school
wear second time exclusive here at Gard
Park cat karaoke Missy's funky white
sister is in the
park in the park
[Music]
dude No Nonsense at all is it let me
work it I put my thing now flip it and
reverse it
SHP he
sh got a big let me
search if you got a big let me search
you dude so no
nonsense dude this is unbelievable man
holy [__] the short hair and the [__]
moomo you know just killing it find out
how hard I got to work yeah he's your
this wi he's your if
dude imagine like making love with this
woman just oh oh oh it would be like
that the whole time I like to get to
know oh beat the [__] up she said 60m
give me all your so I can pH you you
then call me over let me ask a question
why is everybody at the park not losing
their [__] they're just like having a
picnic and stuff she like yeah so anyway
I talked to Jake the other day did you
hear hear it yeah no so he's going to be
out of commission for a while he broke
he broke he broke his foot yeah yeah so
in the meantime you got [__] you know
a principal just it's
Nerf on the B lay me on your before
come you do you don't
you like a see my hips and my chips
don't see my ass in my lips don't you I
lost few pounds in my whips for you this
kind of be to go rat
you SE me go to say blah blah blah work
it I need a glass of water boy boy good
is it let
me now and reverse dude
incredible incredible